ξεχάνινουμε ξεχαννουμενο ότι δημοκραηοσαιερμος και νπο μας συγγεντρωτικόν το οποίον ού ούλα τούτα τα χρόνια
είναι στρατευμένι εργοδωτούμενη μιας δδογμής και πάει είναι ένα μια συμβαχεία μια πάρα για αυτό
νο μας δεν παράταξη είναι μια συμμαχία πο τάσεις απόψεις ανθρώπους που μεγαλώσαμε μαζί να
νθρώπους που γαλουχήθηκαν μαζί μέσα πό εδε ότι ιδεές και ρά τα πρόσωβα είτε μας
αρέσειτε μας άταστα πρόσωβα λαμβανούν πολύ λιγότερη να αξία από αυτή που νομίζουν τα ίσως
και τα ίδια τα προσωπα να ταξί ταν οι ανθρώπι συνδέουνται μεδεσμούς όταν συνδέονται με
ιδές όταν συνδένται με μια αντίληψη γενική για το πως πρέπει να πάει κάτι μπροστά
μπορεί να διαφωνούν με την απόψη που είπα πριν μισό λεπτό για το εντα λος
υ μπορούμε να λύσουμε την εφωδιαστική να λυσία ααλλά να το συζητήσουμε και να φτάσουμε
κάτι δεν μπορεί τούτε ανθρώποι που μεγαλώσα μαζί τούτε ανθρι που εγαλουθχήθηκαν μαζί που ευβρεθηκαν
μαζ που ήταν μαζί να πομε ότε έθα τρόσιμετμτση νεάθα όμως την ίδι ανώρα η
προσπάθειες που γίνονται οιόποιες δήποτε ενέργειες που γίνονται για να μην εφαρμόζουνται η αποφάσεις του
κόμματος είναι λάθος αλλον και στον τσαγερμό είμαστε νανοικτόν κόμμα όποιο θέλει να πει κάτι
πορεί να πείμε στο συαερμό και να πει κύρι εγώ θεωρό πρέπει α πάμε τι
συγκρέρνεση εγώ θεωρώ πρέπει να πάμε με κρέπε αντιπορίδευψη να αποδόμησης ποράν το οποίε όποιο
θέλει εναι τούτε αποφαση όκουμε πόφασης οκομε ας είναι αντιπολίδεση επικοδομητική αυτή πρέπει να φαρμόζουμε
μέχρι να αλλάξει και ούλοι μας όποιες και ένα ανισχέσεις μαμε ος ανθρώπους γύρω μας